la marine le pen est dans nos studios la
vice présidente du front national est
l'invité de pierre boucheny à une panne
bosworth
avant d'aborder les questions d'ordre
national puisque vous n'êtes pas
candidate en région centre tout de même
cette situation évoquée par là des
manifestants en 1998 en région centre
peut-être vous souvenez-vous 15 élus du
front national avait fait alliance avec
le rpr et l'udf pendant huit jours pour
une présidence commune
quelles leçons en tirez-vous ce fut un
échec ici mais pas ailleurs
oui on en a tiré honnêtement et les
français n'ont tiré aucun avantage
l'ump et l'udf ont fait élire dans
beaucoup de régions des exécutifs de
gauche ils ont géré d'ailleurs les
régions avec la gauche ce qui me fait
les appeler aujourd'hui l'ump s et de
façon le mode de scrutin vous savez a
changé mais même s'il n'avait pas changé
je crois que nous ne nous lancerions
plus dans ce type d'opération puisque
ils ne font rien ils n'ont rien fait
hier il ne proposerait aujourd'hui ils
ne feront rien demain alors pourquoi et
d une droite velléitaire impuissante
j'irai presque comme dircom le
porte-parole du gouvernement
je me sens aucun point commun ni avec la
gauche ni avec la droite alors bye nos
peines qui dominent l'actualité
nationale aujourd'hui c'est la question
de l'avenir du système de santé
est-ce que vous au front national vous
êtes sur les bases du système de santé
de solidarité nationale telles qu'elles
ont été définies à la libération
ou est-ce que vous rêvez de privatiser
ce système de santé non je pense surtout
qu'il faut le réserver aux français je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les chiffres de
l'immigration qui restent secrets
d'ailleurs qu'on ne donne pas qu'on est
obligé d'aller chercher dans des
organismes sont assez inquiétants et
c'est un poids sur la communauté
nationale qui pèse alors il suffirait
peut-être de dire que si des étrangers
veulent venir en france eh bien il faut
qu'il s'assume financièrement que les
français eux ont une situation
économique très difficile et qui ne
peuvent plus le faire
je pense qu on réglerait une bonne
partie du problème du déficit du système
de santé alors propos de chiffres de
l'immigration ce n'est pas ce que dit
l'ined institut national geographic
mais bon on va pas polémiquer là-dessus
ce soit par contre ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir c'est quelle système de
santé vous prévoyez alors disons pour
les français une fois que vous en auriez
exclus les immigrés bah écoutez je pense
qu'en tout cas on parle dans le mauvais
sens lorsqu'il s'agit de dérembourser
des médicaments
on se rend bien compte
pays que l'on paye de plus en plus cher
pour obtenir de moins en moins de
protection bon y croyez moi croyez moi
bien que si vous voulez parler de l'ined
on peut en parler l'ined parle de 200
mille immigrés légaux qui rend dans
notre pays par an et l'insee ne parle
que de 50 milles c'est pour ça que
lorsque les chiffres sont officiels même
lorsqu'ils viennent de deux organismes
officiels
je préfère me méfier puisque ces 2 1 ak
je repose ma question quand même sur
votre remède aux remèdes qui passe mal
du point de vue financier tout de même
comment vous les financer si c'était
comme angers finance quoi le système de
santé
je crois que le système de santé
français est un bon système s'il ne
tient pas compte encore une fois du
poids important que qui pèsent sur la
communauté nationale et qui est le poids
de l'immigration je suis désolé de le
dire mais vous savez bien que le déficit
du système de santé s'est accrue dans
des conditions considérable depuis qu'on
a mis en place la kul la couverture
maladie universelle
bon on nous parle moi je veux bien qu'on
continue à mentir aux français
pendant très longtemps enfin on peut au
moins leur dire cette parcelle de vérité
que tout à fait évidemment la couverture
maladie universelle a été à l'origine de
l'aggravation assez fantastique et très
rapide de ce déficit
et ça voudrait dire que des gens qui se
trouvent peut-être effectivement en
situation irrégulière mais d'autres
aussi qui sont simplement sans
ressources ne serait plus soignée et
peut-être serait-il contagieux en dehors
de l'aspect humanitaire de la question
ne s'est pas des gens qui sera atteint
de tuberculose par exemple et qui
seraient dans la nature et non soignée
ça vous paraît pas important mais c'est
bien pour ça voyez vous que je crois
qu'il faut avoir une vision globale de
la politique et que prendre la politique
par petites portions n'est pas une bonne
solution
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il faut
régler à la base le système de le
problème de l'immigration comme
d'ailleurs ont commencé à le faire les
pays européens qui sont autour de nous
comme a commencé à le faire monsieur
hasna lorsqu'il n'a dit qu'il n'avait
plus les moyens d'assumer la d'apporter
la sécurité la santé l'éducation aux
immigrés voilà ce que je crois je pense
que si l'on met en place si on leur dit
écouter ceux qui viennent doivent venir
que si un emploi ne peut pas être rempli
par un français et s'ils peuvent
s'assumer financièrement
eh bien je pense que les pompes
aspirantes de l'immigration seront ainsi
coupé donc l'immigration est la cause de
tous mais ce n'est pas de tous mais la
chose importante du problème économique
france
alors justement propos de problèmes
économiques français il y à un autre
déficit beaucoup plus global qui est
celui des comptes publics de les comptes
de la nation
comment feriez vous à l'avenir si vous
aviez le pouvoir pour les rééquilibrer
sachant que j'ai cru comprendre que vous
souhaitiez supprimer l'impôt sur le
revenu oui mais en réalité la
suppression de l'impôt sur le revenu va
créer des richesses plutôt que que des
déficits voyez vous parce que lorsque la
passion de revenus vous savez c'est
l'impôt sur les travailleurs la peau et
oui c'est l'impôt sur les travailleurs
c'est la fois sur ceux qui travaillent
et moi j'avoue que je suis étonné
l'avenue pas le juste fait le revenu est
gérée on commencerait par les faibles
revenus voyez-vous ont commencé par les
deux premières tranches
et moi je crois que je trouve que ça
étonnant d'ailleurs que la gauche ne
soit pas pour la suppression de l'impôt
sur le revenu voilà parce que je pense
que si on laisse justement l'argent de
leur travail ou français et bien tout à
fait évidemment ça va booster la
croissance ça va permettre de remettre
en branle cette machine qui est
totalement grippé et dont on voit que
elle est en plus alourdi
considérablement
excusez-moi par par le poids de la
fonction publique bruno pennes je vous
remercie d'avoir apporté ici ce soir vos
solutions